So our next class of biomolecule
that we're going to talk about are
nucleic acids.
And we can, for the most part,
describe their properties by
considering just covalent bonds and
hydrogen bonds.
Although, that's a bit of an
oversimplification.
But, anyway, these are,
again, polymers.
So this is DNA and RNA,
terms you've undoubtedly heard.
And these are made by splitting out
water.  And, in this case,
the monomeric units are given the
special term nucleotide.
And a nucleotide consists of a
sugar with something called
a base on it.
It's got a phosphate group at one
end and a hydroxyl group,
one of the sugar hydroxyls that we
saw the other day at the other end.
The B stands for base.
And the way the bond is formed,
as I said, is by splitting out water
like that to form what's known as a
phosphodiester bond.
And we'll be talking a lot about
those when we talk about DNA and RNA
in more detail later on in the
course.  The sugars are pentoses
where N equals 5.
We were talking about these the
other day.  The base goes in this
position.  That's the 1 position
of the carbon.
This is the 5 position of the carbon.
And this is where the phosphate is
located.  This sugar is called
ribose.  And then RNA,
which is the polymer of nucleotides
that have ribose as the sugar is
ribonucleic acid or RNA,
as you've known it.  If this
hydroxyl here is replaced by a
hydrogen and the rest
of it's the same --
-- this is deoxyribonucleoside.
And if you polymerize that together
then you get DNA or deoxyribonucleic
acid.
The bases come in two flavors.
And this will be on your handout.
Ones that either have two rings,
adenine or guanine.
And the general term of those is
purine or they have one ring of
pyrimidine.  And in DNA one finds
cytidine and thiamine abbreviated as
C and T.  Or in RNA,
instead of finding thiamine you find
uracil, which is the same except
that it doesn't have the methyl
group that's present at this
position on thiamine.
And the important thing about these
particular nucleotide bases is that
they can form hydrogen bonds in a
very special way.
It's diagramed on here that this is
a guanine pairing with the cytidine,
so a G pairing with a C.  And you
can form three hydrogen bonds.
Or between an A, an adenine and a
thiamine you can form
two hydrogen bonds.
Those are just the things we were
diagramming on the board the other
day.  And those are the forces that
hold the strands of DNA together so
that DNA is the double helix,
as you know.  It's basically a
backbone with sugars and phosphates.
And then there'll be some sequence
of bases down this.
And then on the other strand you'll
have the base that can form hydrogen
bonds with this.
So C, there would be three hydrogen
bonds here.  This would be a G on
this side, again,
three hydrogen bonds.
If there's an A here that will be a
T there, two hydrogen bonds.
And so on down.  And we'll talk
about the implications of this later
in the course when we talk about DNA
replication, but for the moment I
think your eye can see,
you can probably see that the
geometric arrangement of these is
just exactly the same,
whether it's a G-C or it's an A-T
base pair.  You can superimpose them,
and they have just exactly the same
molecular structure.
And that's really crucial for a lot
of things having to do with DNA.
So, as you know, it's not just sort
of a ladder with hydrogen bonds.
It's twisted in 3-dimensional space.
That's the double helix.
And in that little movie I showed
you the nitrogen atoms and the bases
are blue so you can pretty much pick
it out that there's a series of
hydrogen bonds going right down the
middle of a DNA molecule with the
phosphoribose backbone
on the outside.
So every one of your cells,
since you have about 3 billion base
pairs you have two point something
times that many hydrogen bonds
holding your DNA together.
The thing to remember about the
strength of the hydrogen bond,
it's about a twentieth a covalent
bond, and so you're able to pull
those things apart and then put them
back together at physiological
temperature while leaving all the
covalent bonds that make up each
strand of the DNA leaving
those intact.
It's also possible,
since RNAs are usually
single-stranded,
that if you have a little sequence
here that has the complimentary
sequence over there then these can
pair like this forming a hairpin or
some little structure like that.
And, again, we'll talk about
transfer RNAs which play a really
key role in protein synthesis.
They're the little translators that
go back and forth between the
nucleic acid code,
the genetic code and the protein
code, which is written
in amino acids.
And this just shows making an RNA
copy for a tRNA gene from the DNA,
but then these are the relationships
between the complimentary sequences
right in that strand.
So this thing is able to fold up
into a sort of cloverleaf structure
that some of you have certainly
probably seen at some point.
It's a little bit twisted here
because you can see how the
complimentary sequences
have found each other.
And even though this is just a
single strand of RNA,
by forming hydrogen bonds to
complimentary sequences within
itself it can take up a structure.
And I'll show you.  It actually
goes on, there are some other forces
that come in.  And this will fold up
into a 3-dimensional structure that
goes even beyond what I've shown you,
but we won't need to talk about that
for just a little bit.  OK.
So then the next --
-- class of molecules that we're
going to spend a lot of this course
on are proteins.  And these
are polymers again.
-- made by splitting out water.
So that's been true of
polysaccharides.
It's true of nucleic acids.
It's true of proteins.  In this
case the monomers are structures
known as amino acids.
And they have an amino group.
And then it's joined to a carbon
known as the alpha carbon.
And then there's a carboxyl group.
So this is why they're called amino
acids, because their carboxyl
group is an acid.
And the way they form --
We'll give these different side
chains here.  I'll tell you about
these side chains in just a minute.
The way these form a bond is by
splitting out water here.
And then this will give this very
important bond in nature --
-- which is known as the peptide
bond.  And there's a chemical
property of this that's important.
Someone was bemoaning the fact that
I had to go over a bunch of
chemistry and they hadn't liked 5.
11.  My apologies.
But we won't be spending all course
doing chemistry.
But if you want to understand how
these things work you do need to
understand some of the chemical
principles to understand them.
And this is a case where it's
really important because,
although it's written this way with
the double bond here and a single
bond there, this double bond
actually sort of spends part of its
time over here.
So this is actually sort of a
partial double bond.
And that has an important
consequence because if you're a
single bond, if you remember a
single bond can bend and stretch but
it can also rotate.
But if you're a double bond you
cannot rotate.
So the peptide bond,
and you make a lot of these when
you're polymerizing amino acids
together to make proteins,
those bonds have a very special
character that they cannot rotate.
Now, let me say, I'll come back and
show you why that's important in
just a moment.
But let me just say a word about
the side chains.
There are 20 different amino acids.
And they have side chains that have
very different chemical properties.
And when we start thinking about how
a chain of amino acids take up the
properties that make it into an
enzyme or part of a motor or a
structural protein or into your
finger nails or your hair or skin,
they have to have very special
properties.  And it's the sequence
of these different amino acids with
their different chemical properties
that are eventually going to let
each protein form up to one
particular 3-dimensional structure
that will give it its
characteristics.
So the different types of amino
acids, and again you won't have to
memorize these,
but here they are up here.
But let me just point out the
important classes,
because the thing you really want to
do with this one is to remember the
types of amino acids we find.
There are negatively charged amino
acids.
An example of this would be
aspartate.  Under physiological
conditions, although this is an acid,
it will dissociate so it will have a
negative charge.
And that's abbreviated as A-S-P.
Glutamine is another one that has a
negative charge.
There are also amino acids that
have positive charges
on the side chain.
An example of this would be lysine
which has four methylene groups.
And then it has an amino group.
But, again, under physiological
conditions, around pH 7,
that will be protonated so it will
have a plus charge.
And that is lysine or L-Y-S.
And arginine and histidine are two
other amino acids that have a
positive charge, or can have
a positive charge.
Then there's a set of amino acids
that have a polar character.
They don't have a full charge.
And, as you might guess, they have
one of the bonds that we've talked
about that are polar.
This is serine.
Serine.  There's another one that
has a hydroxyl that's
known as threonine.
And then there is a glutamine and
asparagine, both of which have an
N-H bond.  So just through what I've
told you here,
we haven't even been through the set,
you can see how you can begin to
decorate an amino acid chain.
So there's a plus charge and a
minus charge, a polar charge.
There's a tremendous amount of
diversity because at every single
thing you have a choice of 20 things
you can put in.
So they not only have size and
shape characteristics,
but they have particular charges and
other properties.
Then, as always,
there are a bunch of special,
oh, excuse me.  Actually, before we
do that, we have hydrophobic.
Or you could think of these as
greasy or water-hating.
These are the ones that are sort of
when I was talking about trying to
dissolve butter into water.
These are things that don't like to
interact with water or cannot
interact with water,
and so they cannot form hydrogen
bonds so you cannot get them to go
under water easily.
And they come from very simple ones
that have just the methyl group
which is alanine or A-L-A or one
like this which would be CH2-CH with
a couple of methyl groups.
This is even more water-hating,
that would be lucien, L-E-U.
Or here's one that you probably
could guess that really doesn't
interact with water.
This is phenylalanine or P-H-E.
And you can see what this side
chain is.  It's a methylene group.
And what's dangling off it but a
benzene ring.  And I think most of
you remember from probably beginning
chemistry that benzene is something
that you cannot dissolve
sugar in or something.
It's an organic solvent.
It will only dissolve things that
have a very hydrophobic character.
Then there are some special cases.
Glycine is one,
because in this case the side chain
is simply a hydrogen atom.
And, as a consequence to that,
this is a very flexible amino acid.
So if you want to build --
If nature wants to build a loop into
a protein, it's going to undergo a
tight turn.  You often find glycines
there because there's not a big side
chain to get in the way if you're
going to be bending the chain in
3-dimensional space.
Another one is cysteine,
which looks like serine over there,
but it has a thiol group instead of
a hydroxyl group.
And that's important because that
allows for the formation of another
special type of bond that if you
have one chain of protein that has a
cysteine on it and another
polypeptide chain that has a
cysteine on it and they're close
together in space,
what can happen is you can form a
covalent bond between these under
oxidative conditions.
This is known as a disulfide bond.
That's covalent.
So those two chains,
if that bond occurs, are now sort of
semi-permanently locked together.
They're locked together in a very,
very strong way.  So this is a
feature of, this is the only
intrastrand covalent bond that you'd
characteristically find in proteins.
All the rest of them we're going to
show you, when they fold up in
3-dimensional space,
depend on other kinds of
interactions.
And finally there's one last case
which is proline.
And this one is a little different
because in the amino acid the side
chain bends around like this and
joins here.  So it's actually
forming a little circle here between
the nitrogen, the amino group and
the carboxyl group.
And the consequence of this is this
bond cannot rotate.
The bond that would normally be
able to rotate is not able to do
that.  And so this is sort of a
protein you find that when there are
some of these regular structures,
I'm going to show you in a minute,
like helices and things, this
protein won't,
this amino acid particularly won't
fit into those structures.
So you tend to, if nature wants to
interrupt a particular regular
structure that's coming,
it will often find a proline right
at that particular point.
OK.  So what we've talked about up
until now is sort of just the very,
very basic piece of protein
structure.
It's what called the primary
structure which is nothing more than
the sequence of amino acids.
However, here's a little piece of
protein.  This is polyalanine.
And one thing you can sort of see
is if I was trying to figure out how
to fold this up into a 3-dimensional
confirmation.
And let's say this had 300 amino
acids or something,
there are essentially an infinite
number of confirmations.
And so one of the real holy grails
still in biology is trying to
understand if you see the linear
sequence of an amino acid,
which we can now deduce, excuse me,
of a protein, of an amino.  If you
see the linear sequence of amino
acids in a protein,
and we can deduce those from
analyzing genomes and so on,
how do we go from a thing that says
a tryptophan, a cysteine,
a serine, a serine, a threonine,
whatever down the chain to finding
its 3-dimensional structure and
ultimately its role?
And you can sort of hopefully get a
sense from this of why it's
important.  So there are levels this
goes.  The next level is what's
known as secondary structure.
These are regions of local
secondary structure and they're
determined by hydrogen bonds.
And I'll show you how these go in
just a second.
And then you can think about
proteins in the tertiary structure.
So what we've done and sort of
taken a chain and then found out how
a little region might take up a
particular, for example,
here's a portion that's in a helix.
This is fairly rigid right now
because of the way it's held
together.  And we'll then find maybe
another region like a beta sheet I'm
going to show you in a minute.
Ultimately we have to figure out how
all these units fold up into a
3-dimensional structure.
And what we get there is called the
tertiary structure.
And this has some other forces
we're going to talk about besides
covalent bonds and hydrogen bonds
that determine that.
And then, as I've tried to tell you,
you can see that proteins play a lot
of roles in nature and they're not
all single proteins running around
being an enzyme or something
like that.
Many of them are parts of machines
so they're made to fit together in
absolutely beautiful ways.
Some of them have, at this point,
fifty-hundred parts that all go
together fitting shapes and
interacting with these shapes on the
principles that we'll be talking
about here, the different forces
that make things happen in nature.
And so quaternary means the
structure when there's more than one
polypeptide chain.
So getting a handle on protein
structure was kind of a very
important intractable problem for a
long time because it was just too
hard a nut to crack,
but in the 1930s and 1940s x-ray
crystallography started to come into
usage where basically you'd bounce
x-rays off of a crystal.
And then they would refract and
you'd see characteristic reflections.
And you could work backwards to
figure out what the structure of the
crystal was.  This had been applied
to minerals and a lot of structure,
but it hadn't been applied to
proteins.  When people started to
look they found there were certain
proteins that gave characteristic
reflections.  Carotin,
for example.  Your hair gives a
characteristic reflection around 5.
angstroms.  So that suggested that
there was a repeating unit somewhere
in carotin that had this.
And, again, with artificial peptides
sometimes they were able to see
these reflections.
And so that was where things stood
for a while.  And then one of these
secondary structures,
a very, very important one known as
the alpha helix was deduced by Linus
Pauling.  Some of you have heard of
him.  He was a famous chemistry at
Caltech.  He got the Nobel prize.
He also got famous later in his
career because he championed the use
of vitamin C to cure every ill known
to mankind, including
the common cold.
Although there's some merit to what
Linus stated, he probably overstated
some of those later findings,
but his contributions to the
underlying chemistry and
biochemistry of proteins was amazing.
And he was the one that figured out
the structure that explained the 5.
angstrom repeat.
And it was kind of an interesting
story.  He was in Oxford,
England.  And he got sick.
I think it was some time in the
winter.  And he got bored reading
detective books after a while so he
thought he'd try and figure out the
structure of proteins that gave rise
to this characteristic repeat.
So he made a simplifying assumption.
He decided he'd forget all the side
chains and just focus on this
peptide backbone just with
the peptide bond.
And he was a chemist.
And he knew, what I just told you,
that this had a partial double bond
character so it couldn't rotate.
And he reasoned that this was held
together by, since these things
could form hydrogen bonds that this
was probably forming a hydrogen bond
with a carboxyl group of some other
amino acid and this was probably
forming a hydrogen bond with an
amino group of a different
amino acid.
And so what he did was he made a
sort of chain like this and he
started to pleat it at the alpha
carbon, which is the one that has
the side chain on it,
and was finding to trying to
structure that would let him do this.
And basically what he found was
that if he made a helix that looks
something like this,
right-handed helix, and he could get
a repeat structure that allowed him
to form a hydrogen bond.
you can build a tremendous amount of
diversity even within that helical
And the repeating unit was 5.
angstroms and 3.7, excuse me,
amino acids per turn.  And it's a
right-handed helix.
It's the same sort of thing if
you're trying to turn in a screw.
It's got that kind of structure.
And this shows you a little movie of
an alpha helix.
You can see this is just showing
is if you put on the side chains,
and you can put them on in any order,
the backbone.  So this is the part
you can look right down
the end of it.
See how you can look right though?
And you can see how the hydrogen
bonds are formed by turning this
thing into this regular structure.
And the neat thing about this then
structure.  I think I can stop this.
I just want to show you one thing,
if I can manage to this when it
comes around again.  Stop it there.
One of the things you can see,
now we're looking down the helix.
And although you won't recognize
the structures of all the amino
acids right away,
you may be able to see in this
particular one.
Here are a couple of aromatic rings
off on this side.
So this side of the helix wouldn't
like to see water,
and over here are a bunch of charged
and polar amino acids.
So you could see how you could
build into a helix like that,
a surface, one part that wouldn't
like to interact with water and
another part that would.
So that was an extremely important
contribution.  And there are alpha
helices in almost all proteins.
They'll be in little chunks coming
down an amino acids chain.
But they'll take up that structure.
And, as you can see, it's driven by
these hydrogen bonds that we've been
talking about.
There turns out then to be a second
type of secondary structure that's
important.  It's called
a beta sheet.
And in this case you can either line
up two polypeptide chains running in
the same orientation,
amino to carboxyl, amino to carboxyl,
or you can run them in opposite
orientations, amino to carboxyl,
amino to carboxyl in the other way.
The latter one is called an
anti-parallel beta sheet.
And if you line things up this way
you'll see you can find hydrogen
bonds between the chains like that.
So this allows two things to form
in this way and gives a sort of
sheet-like structure.
Whereas, that alpha helix has this
tight coil like this.
So over here I think we have a
movie of a beta sheet.
And you'll see again you can build
up more than one.
Because if you look up here you can
see how you are all set up to form
more hydrogen bonds out in that kind
of way.  And, as I said,
you can do this same trick putting
the polypeptide chains so they have
the same polarity.
And so you can approximate,
look at the structure of most
proteins then by depicting them
either as alpha helices,
which you'll see in these diagrams.
You've already seen a few in the
examples given.
They'll look like this.
Or a beta sheet which are indicated
as these flat arrows.
So here's a little piece of a
protein made up of alpha helix,
these beta sheets.  What this is,
actually, is a piece of the BRCA-1
gene.  That's the familial
susceptibility to breast cancer.
The gene that causes that is called
BRCA-1.  And it has a special
interaction domain called
the BRC T domain.
This is the structure.
And the only point I'm trying to
make, it's of a protein that's
involved in preventing you from
getting breast cancer.
If you get a mutation in it,
or particularly in this region,
for example, you can end up with an
increased susceptibility to breast
cancer.  But what is it?
It's an alpha helices beta sheet.
There's green fluorescent protein.
You've seen that a few times.
Maybe now you'll recognize it's
mostly made of beta sheets.
There's a little bit of alpha helix
down there, a little
bit right there.
And that has the property that we've
talked about of fluorescing.
This is a protein I'll tell you
later on that recognizes mismatches
in DNA, and you get a susceptibility
to cancer if it breaks.
The only thing you notice here are
a lot of alpha helices in it.
And hopefully already your eye can
begin to pick these out.
This is an enzyme.  What it does is
it's got a catalytic ability to
cleave other polypeptide chains.
The functions of these don't matter.
But you can see once again alpha
helices beta sheets.
Here's another one.
It looks just about the same,
alpha helices, beta sheets, except
in this case this is the human gene
known as, the protein encoded by
human genes called RAS.
That's an oncogene.  That's a gene
that if it mutates in a particular
way will cause the cell that has
that to move a step down the pathway
to cancer.  So what I've done is put
up a whole lot of structures that
have some alpha helices,
some beta sheets.
But you can get the idea that you
can get very, very different
biological activities from just
depending on how you arrange those.
OK.  So there are a couple of other
then forces that I need to tell you
about if we're going to go all the
way to understanding the
3-dimensional structure of proteins.
What we can get to from that is
alpha helices beta sheets.
But you saw there were loops,
there were other interactions that I
haven't accounted for in showing you
those 3-dimensional structures.
So one of them are ionic bonds.
This is the third class of force.
This is an extreme case of electron
sharing where one atom gets all of
the electrons.
So aspartate, which I had up on the
board, aspartic acid looks like that,
but under physiological conditions
the oxygen will get all the
electrons and you'll have
a hydrogen on it.
And a consequence of that then is
that if you have a polypeptide chain
that over here has an aspartate and
over here has a lysine,
which is the four methylene groups,
and the positively charged thing
here, you can get an ionic bond
between those two amino acids that
can be very far apart on
the polypeptide chain.
There may be a lot of amino acids in
between, but what they then do is
bring these two points together and
hold them like that.
The next class of force is kind of
tricky.  You may have heard of it in
chemistry.  It's referred to as van
der Waals interaction.
And the basis of this,
without going into it too much,
is even a nonpolar bond --
-- can have a transient polarity.
And this then induces --
-- a transient polarity in a nearby
bond.  And it has to be a really
nearby bond.  So about 0.
to 0.4 nanometers.  Remember,
covalent bonds are roughly half that
distance or something.
So it's got to be a very,
very close interaction.  It's weak.
It's only one-third to one-quarter
of a hydrogen bond,
which you may recall is about
one-twentieth of a covalent bond.
But there can be many,
many of them if the surfaces fit
together really,
really tightly.  So if you have a
protein fold, so there's a surface
here, and then it folds up in such a
way that there's a surface here,
then you can get a lot of van der
Waals interactions down here.
Now, I've never had a really good
way of explaining this.
But today, part of these activities
of this Hughes Professorship,
I've set up some seminars on
teaching.
And I've invited a guy from Berkley
named Robert Full who is talking in
68.180 at 4:00 PM.
And I borrowed some things from him
this morning.  And we're just going
to take a quick tour because I want
to show you this.
He works on, well,
he does a lot of things.
He works on biomotion and how
animals work.
But one of the things he works on,
let's see if we can get this guy to
go here.  Oops.
How do I figure out how to get it
to play here?  Hang on a second.
I just discovered that the
PowerPoint is not really
terribly effective.
So this isn't working as nicely as I
would like.  OK.
Let's try this.  Just a minute.
Where are we?  Here we go.  OK.
Let's see if I can get this to go.
So he studies a bunch of things,
but he did an undergrad project
library studying geckos.
And here this is a transparent
surface.  And he's studying how the
geckos climb up and down the thing.
And they were making measurements.
And they found they couldn't
account for why this was such an
efficient organism.
It used much less energy than most
things, so they started looking into
how it adhered to the surface.
It can go up a vertical wall, as
you can see here.
And so they were able to look
underneath and they could see,
see how it sort of peels off the
surface?  And this was a robot that
they eventually built that's not
using the same molecular bases but
uses this peeling thing.
And they can get a robot that
climbs up a wall.
But that's not what we're going to
talk about here.
We're going to instead,
I hope, go back to here.  And you
can see that all of the geckos have
these sort of bizarre toes,
and so they started looking to see
what the underlying principle of
this was.  And they saw it has these
setae.  And they got looking in
greater detail and blew it up.
And then they found that there were,
as they started looking there were
these little hairs.
And that's a 900 fold magnification.
And once they got looking in more
detail they found the ends were
split so that they were,
the very ends are about 200
nanometers roughly at the end of
this.  And so a gecko has about a
billion of these on its feet.
And what it turns out it does --
And just to see,
here's a human hair.
You see how it splits down?
Now, this is made of keratin,
the molecule I just mentioned that
was used, alpha helices,
but it's very, very fine.
And what it can do, it can make van
der Waals interactions.
This is an animal that sticks to
the wall by van der Waals
interactions.  And the peeling away
allows it to break those bonds.
But, as you can see, they're
enormously important.
He's got here a micrograph.
They're measuring the force,
and the force is just huge.  This is
the end of the thing,
the frayed end sticking to a surface.
And for those of you who didn't
think biology any relevance to you,
Bob was telling me about this.  They
followed up, he's an engineer as
well and builds interdisciplinary
teams, and they've measured this
stuff.  But this is turning into
what appears to look like it's going
to be a $30 to $50 billion industry
as all sorts of things are --
They're beginning to realize it can
hold car parts together,
it can go in space shuttles,
Post-it notes.  And here's a little
Band-Aid they made.
They own the patent on this
self-cleaning dry adhesive.
It doesn't have to be made out of
gecko stuff.  It could be made out
of all sorts of things.
But, anyway, here's an example of
where not only are van der Waals
forces very important,
but where somebody who started a
very simply aspect of biology
worrying about the efficiency of how
geckos ran and pushed it all the way
down to the molecular level
understood a principal that's going
to make somebody a very
large amount of money.
OK.  The last,
and if anybody wants to come,
he's an amazing speaker.  Perhaps
one of the most exciting speakers
I've ever heard.
68-180, 4:00 PM if you want to go.
He'll have more of that sort of
stuff to show you then.  OK.
So the last force here,
it's not really a force,
but what we'll call hydrophobic
effects.  And what I mean by this is
that the principle of this is that
amino acids that don't like to
interact with water, so --
So hydrophobic amino acids.
These are ones like lucien and
phenylalanine.
Well, I showed you the water the
other day and how it was forming
hydrogen bonds between the molecules.
So if you're going to stick another
molecule in there,
you're going to break a bunch of
bonds.  And if you're not charged or
polar you cannot make new bonds with
the water.  And so what happens,
if you put these together, just like
if you put oil together it will all
bundle up and it will minimize its
interactions with water.
And that's what proteins do.
Here's the structure of a protein
all folded up in 3-dimensional space.
And you can see at the core of the
protein how there are these many
hydrophobic amino acids that are
interacting.  And let me just,
I'm going to close by showing you
one more little movie.
And the new version of PowerPoint
doesn't do this well so I'm just
going to get out of this
for a second here.
This is a really cool movie I saw.
I want to show you a DNA repair
protein sticking to a piece of helix.
Can you hit the lights somebody
there?  So this is a lesion on a
piece of, see the double
helix here?
And what I especially liked about
this is this is sort of a Star Wars
movie.  You're going to fly down the
major groove of a double helix.
And you can see where this
particular protein folded up in
3-dimensional space is reaching down
into that helix.
So this is sort of putting together
the two things that I've been
telling you about.
This blue is a DNA repair protein.
Oopsy daisy.
A DNA repair protein that's able to
find a lesion in the DNA.
And here's the double helix that's
the two chains held together by
hydrogen bonds.
And then, as you can see,
there's a groove on each side.
And the protein is searching down
into that groove --